الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا فقد
اعلن الجيش الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه
شنت هجوما صاروخيه واسعه النطاق على خمس
مقاطعات في شرق ووسط وغرب البلاد وقالت
الاداره العسكريه في خرسون ان شخصين قتل
وانها اربعه اخرين اصيبوا في قصف الروسي
فقالت الاداره العسكريه للعاصمه
نحو 20 صاروخا بينما كشف عمده
سبعه مدنيين
وتضرر مباني مدنيه وسيارات
واعلنت الاداره العسكريه في الفيف وقوع
اصابات بين المدنيين بعد هجوم تعرضت له
المدينه
بدورها اعلنت الاداره العسكريه لخاركيد ان
القوات الروسيه استهدفت المدينه بعده
صواريخ
وقد استهدف الهجوم الصاروخي الروسي في
منطقه شيركاس وسط اوكرانيا وقالت وحده
الطوارئ الحكوميه ان حصيله جرح الهجوم
الصاروخي الروسي ارتفع الى عشره اشخاص
مدنيين اصيبوا وتم اخراجه احد عشر شخصا من
بين الانقاض بعد الهجوم الذي يستهدف فندقا
وسوقا تجاريه
معنى من زبروجيا مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام
الياس مرحبا بك معنا من جديد اذا قتلى
وجرحى والحديث عن مناطق مختلفه من شرق
البلاد الى غربها ما خطوره هذا الهجوم
الروسيه الجديد
بالفعل وربما يكون الاوسع في الاسابيع
الاخيره الذي يطال محافظات مختلفه في
اوكرانيا وكذلك العاصمه الاوكرانيه حيث
كانت الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه بحسب
السلطات العسكريه هناك قد اعترضت 20
صاروخا في سماء العاصمه كييف وحدها وبعض
الشظايا التي نجمت عن اعتراض الصواريخ في
سماء المدينه سقطت على مناطق ماهوله وعلى
سيارات كانت تصطفوا قرب بعض المباني مما
اسفر عن وقوع اضرار ماديه وعن اصابه سبعه
اشخاص بجروح القصف الصاروخي ايضا طالع
مدينه خاركب في المناطق الشماليه الشرقيه
للبلاد عمده المدينه تحدث عن اطلاق سته
صواريخ روسيه من نوع اس 300 باتجاه
المدينه مما اسفر عن اصابه شخصين على
الاقل هذه الصواريخ التي كانت معده اصلا
للاعتراض الصواريخ المقاتلات الحربيه
حولتها القوات الروسيه الى صواريخ ارض ارض
وباتت تستخدمها ايضا في توجيه ضربات
صاروخيه للمدن والمواقع
الاوكرانيه على الجهه الغربيه للبلاد
تحديدا في منطقه
السلطات المحليه العسكريه هناك تقول بان
صواريخ طالت منشاه صناعيه مما ادى الى
حدوث حريق فيها دون التبليغ عن وقوع
اصابات وهنالك ايضا هجوم صاروخ اخر طالما
منطقه شركاسي هذه المحافظه الواقعه في وسط
اوكرانيا وهذا الصاروخ ربما كان ناجما عن
الاضرار التي حدثت في فندق هناك وفي سوق
تجاريه يبدو ان هذا كان ناجما عن اعتراض
صاروخ في سماء المدينه الامر الذي اسفر
بحسب اخر تحديث لوحده الطوارئ الحكوميه عن
اصابه عشره اشخاص
واضح بان الهجمات الصاروخيه
الروسيه التي تطال المدن الاوكرانيه تكون
اكثر كثافه خاصه عندما يعلن الجانب
الاوكراني عن استهدافه لمنشات ولمواقع
استراتيجيه روسيه هذا الهجوم ياتي فقط بعد
ساعات من تاكيد الوحده الاستراتيجيه في
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه عن استهداف مقر
القياده العامه لاسطول البحر الاسود في
القرن وياتي ايضا بعد ايام قليله من
تاكيدات اوكرانيه عن استهداف سفينه حربيه
وغواصه في ميناء سيفوستوفو في في القرن
وبالتالي هذا تصعيد من من جانب القوات
الروسيه في هذه الهجمات الصاروخيه التي
تطال المدن الاوكرانيه في عموم اوكرانيا
فيما تتحدث يتحدث الجيش الاوكراني في
تحديثه الصباحي على ان الساعات 24 الماضيه
شملت استهد لنحو تسعين مدينه وبلده في
كافه جبهات القتال ونحن نتحدث عن تسعين
مدينه وبلده اصبحت في خط المواجهه المتقدم
ما بين القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه سواء
كان هنا في المنطقه الجنوبيه في زبالوجيا
او على اقليم دومباس في المناطق الشرقيه
للبلاد حيث تتواصل المعارك ما بين القوات
الاوكرانيه
والروسيه على اكثر من محور في الشرق وعلى
اكثر من محور هنا ايضا في الجنوب من شكرا